apocalyptic scenes here in Baltimore the
aftermath of a night of violent protests
an eruption of pent-up frustration among
the city's black youth rioters
vandalized businesses looted shops
pharmacies and liquor stores as the city
descended into chaos it's not a world
peace which all gotta give us that and
y'all keep coming and taking everything
we got we all take the child got we not
pan out here it's not a look we won
outright the epicenter of the violence
is West Baltimore a predominantly black
neighborhood struggling with high
unemployment and high crime rates for
years people here have been complaining
of racial discrimination and excessive
brutality by white police officers but
the city's black mayor showed little
sympathy for the rioters this is one of
our darkest days as a city and I know
that we're much better than this we know
that the world is watching and we cannot
allow our city to devolve into chaos
because I'm a you know a small group of
criminals it was the latest flare-up
over the death of Freddie gray the
protests began after his funeral
yesterday the 25 year old black man was
arrested on April twelfth and died from
a spinal injury while in police custody
witnesses say he told police he had
asthma and couldn't breathe Gray's death
is the latest of several high-profile
cases beginning with the shooting of
Michael Brown in Ferguson last year that
have fueled racial tensions across the
nation too many hear his death is seen
as further proof that black lives don't
matter